у нас нині немає Мирного процесу є
тільки жорстока війна Тому що Путін досі
не хоче йти на
переговори Бразилія може зіграти свою
роль вона може допомогти підготувати
дипломатичне поле для майбутніх
переговорів Тобто ви вважаєте що
Бразилія може стати посередником між
Росією та Україною
звісно щоб зупинити війну недостатньо
досягти припинення
[музика]
вогню чи повинна Бразилія постачати
Україні зброю це все ще справедливе
очікування з боку українського
суспільства та народу у Німеччині Де ви
були послом України з 2015 по 2022 роки
ви здобули репутацію людини яка відверто
і відкрито критикує місцевих політиків
зокрема й керівництво уряду Чи маєте ви
намір зайняти таку ж позицію тут у
Бразилії Чесно кажучи я ще не знаю який
шлях обрати але скопіювати і вставити не
вдасться оскільки кожна ситуація
унікальна Для мене було великою честю
працювати в Німеччині багато років Я Мав
нагоду працювати там 7 років до
повномасштабного російського
вторгнення причина чому я був таким
відвертим коли почалася війна це не була
вистава Це був щирий крик моєї душі Я не
міг зрозуміти і осягнути чому Німеччина
яка була так залучена в Мінські
переговори у мене за всі ці сім років до
війни були не десятки а сотні зустрічей
у Мінському форматі нормандському
форматі переговори тривали на всіх
рівнях зокрема найвищих знаючи всі
ризики позиція Німеччини щодо України
полягала в тому щоб не давати нам зброї
до початку цієї війни моє особисте
переконання полягає в тому що це
запобігло нинішньому широкомасштабному
російському вторгненню яке почалося в
лютому 2022
року у Бразилії в нас інше завдання
понад 130 років Ми маємо величезну
україномовну спільноту переважно в
парані Сподіваюся відвідати цей штат
найближчим часом
понад 600 000 громадян Бразилії мають
українське походження це те що нас
об'єднує я не думаю що Україна наразі
багато значить для більшості людей тут
Тому мій метод роботи Буде простим
просто розповідати про війну розповідати
що відбувається показувати потреби Є
багато питань які для нас є надзвичайно
важливими тому що на окупованих
територіях на півдні та сході України
росіяни викрадають українких дітей і
насильно вивозять їх до Росії насильно
всиновлюють перевиховують це
відбувається і в той час поки ми з вами
говоримо у X столітті Це честісіньке
варварство якою ви бачите позицію
Бразилії щодо війни в Україні чи
помилкова ця
позиція Я б так не сказав якщо поглянути
на офіційну політику то Бразилія
належить до групи зі 141єї країни які в
лютому на генеральній асамблеї ООН у
першу сумну річницю широкомасштабного
російського вторгнення засудили
вторгнення засудили порушення
міжнародного права а також були частиною
широкої міжнародної спільноти яка
намагається допомогти нам знайти Мирне
вирішення цієї жахливої війни для мене
це має значення Я дуже радий І пишаюся
тим що ми змогли організувати першу
зустріч між між президентами лулою та
Зеленським у нью-йорку чому Тому що досі
вони провели лише одну телефонну розмову
в березні Минулого
року під час останньої зустрічі
відбулася відверта та чесна розмова двох
дуже амбітних лідерів Бразилії та
України без великих очікувань але з
бажанням краще зрозуміти позицію один
одного що Бразилія могла б зробити щоб
зупинити цю жахли війну це те що зараз
важливо який внесок може зробити кожна
велика чи мала держава в глобальному
масштабі щоб зупинити це насильство Це
божевілля яке ми маємо вдень і вночі в
Україні Це був хороший початок Ми навіть
можемо назвати цю зустріч проривом після
замкнутого кола неправильних уявлень
тлумачень і звинувачень які ми відчували
в
минулому у нас нині немає Мирного
процесу
У нас є тільки жорстока війна Тому що
Путін досі не хоче йти на переговори і
це теж було однією з тем зустрічі яку
президенти детально обговорили
Український президент намагався пояснити
президенту лулі чому починати мирні
переговори зараз не мало б сенсу з дуже
простої причини немає Ані найменшої
довіри до того що говорить чи робить
очільник Кремля обіцянки які він дає
порожні слова і не більше це був один із
моментів які намагався пояснити
Український президент Ми хочемо миру
більше ніж будь-яка Інша нація тому що
ми страждали наш
народ Бразилія може зіграти свою роль
вона може допомогти підготувати
дипломатичне поле для майбутніх
переговорів які відбудуться лише тоді
коли настане відповідний час Бразилія
може зробити великий
внесок щоб зупинити ві було б
недостатньо досягти припинення вогню це
також був один із меседжів які намагався
донести Український президент цього
недостатньо для досягнення тривалого
Миру Путін може припинити вогонь так
само як це було після Мінської угоди в
лютому 2015 року це була не мирна угода
а угода про припинення вогню вона не
була реалізована багато країн знехтували
наслідками і на нашій території почалася
війна Тобто ви вважаєте що Бразилія може
стати посередником між Росією та
Україною звісно На мою думку Бразилія
має відігравати більш активну роль з
багатьох причин це справа бразильської
дипломатії це має бути дуже творчий
процес оскільки подібного прикладу в
недалекому минулому не було Це
унікальний випадок вперше постійний член
ради безпеки ООН кує вторгається в
сусідню країну маючи право вето на
будь-яке політичне рішення ООН це одна з
головних проблем нинішнього правового
порядку якому загрожує Росія і немає
інструменту щоб змусити країну агресора
якою є РФ припинити бойові дії припинити
вторгнення тому що Росія може
заблокувати будь-яке рішення радбезу
своїм правом вето ми Закликаємо всіх
бразильських друзів і
мислити нестандартно думати творчо за
допомогою яких засобів і на яких форумах
ми можемо знайти рішення для цієї
найбільшої проблеми людства без
перебільшення це найбільший виклик з
яким зіткнулося людство після Другої
світової
війни чи повинна Бразилія постачати
Україні
зброю це хороше запитання насамперед
Хочу зазначити що Це звісно м суверенне
рішення бразильського уряду тому що
бразильський уряд має подбати про власні
національні інтереси та сформулювати
відповідний курс дій і порядок денний
тому ми враховуємо ту позицію Бразилії
яку ми бачили з самого початку цієї
війни ця війна на
95% ведеться проти мирного населення в
Україні
95% жертв мішеней російських обстрілів з
усіх можливих озброєнь артилерії ракет
кінжалів та оніксів і Чим там ще вони
проти нас користуються основною ціллю
залишається мирне населення Із цієї
точки зору Я вважаю що постачання зброї
- це все ще справедливе очікування з
боку українського суспільства та народу
інші країни Латинської Америки зокрема і
Бразилія також можуть відігравати тут
провідну роль чому Україні так важко
мобілізувати підтримку на глобальному
півдні
це дуже хороше і водночас складне
запитання і ми поки не маємо єдиної
відповіді на нього оскільки воно носить
системний характер є надто багато
факторів які ми на жаль не помічали
Протягом останніх трьох десятиліть після
того як ми відновили нашу незалежність
ми не інвестували багато не лише грошей
але й часу та увагу у відносини з
країнами які зараз повертаються на
глобальну арену в усьому світі у так
званий третій світ глобальний південь Я
ненавиджу цей термін але зараз немає
іншого поняття щоб описати десятки країн
які мають свій шлях які хотіли б
відігравати важливішу роль на
міжнародній арені і це значною мірою
наша власна провина наша помилка що ми
зосередилися здебільшого на наших
ключових питаннях таких як приєднання до
Європейського Союзу чи вступ до НАТО
тому що ми хотіли б бути під їхньою
парасолькою і бути частиною цієї
оборонної
спільноти також наших ресурсів не
вистачало ще і на те щоб звернути увагу
на інші країни які на це заслужили і ми
це бачимо зараз війна показала На жаль
чи може це навіть добре якщо можна
говорити про щось хороше з точки зору
цієї війни Вона відкрила очі українцям
що ми повинні були бути активнішими
президент луїснасіо лула да Сілва
нещодавно заявив що Бразилія не
затримуватиме ра Путіна якщо він
відвідає саміт G20 у Ріо дежанейро в
2024 році пізніше він уточнив що це
рішення будуть ухвалювати бразильські
судові органи що ви думаєте з цього
приводу було стільки коментарів щодо цих
заяв що мені небагато лишається додати
Україна хотіла б аби президента
Зеленського запросили на саміт уріо
наступного року де будуть збиратися усі
лідери великої двадцятки щоб він міг
представити наше питання ми також
повідомляли про це прохання нашим
бразильським друзям чи буде пан Путін на
цій зустрічі чи ні це вирішують наші
бразильські
партнери Хто знає можливо пан Путін не
боятиметься приїхати в Ріо ій бути
заарештованим Я вважаю що це буде цікава
гра або вистава але рішення за
бразильцями наше бажання і прохання
полягає в тому щоб під час головування
Бразилії у Великій 20ці Україна була б
серед учасників неповноправних бо ми не
члени G20 це зрозуміло але Бразилія може
запросити нашу країну як спеціального
гостя щоб ми могли розповісти про
причину війни яку нам доводиться вести
для самооборони адже це війна заради
захисту Ми ведемо цю війну не тому що
нам це подобається не тому що ми хочемо
щоб нас вважали героями а просто тому що
це питання нашого існування Як ви
думаєте чим закінчиться ця
війна для мене як українця як
громадянина України не тільки як для
дипломата чи посла напевно не існує
іншого виходу іншого завершення цієї
війни аніж щоб Україна звільнила усі
окуповані території у тому числі і Крим
Тобто лише тоді коли Україна відновить
свої міжнародновизнані кордони з
1991 року тоді можна буде говорити про
ривали
мир і це важливо підкреслити оскільки ви
мабуть знаєте Та чули що й у Бразилії
були деякі дискусії щодо можливих
компромісів один із варіантів які
пропонувалися можливо Крим потрібно
винести за дужки а Україна просто
повинна звільнити тільки ті території
які були окуповані після 24 лютого 2022
року А для Криму можливо згодом можна
буде знайти інше дипломатичне рішення
це дуже небезпечна логіка бо якщо
міжнародне співтовариство дозволить
такого роду фальшивий компроміс це не
означатиме що може бути встановлений і
гарантований довготривалий мир тому що
поки питання Криму залишається не
вирішеним не може бути справедливого
рішення адже півострів - це не тільки
земля а й український народ мільйони
громадян України все ще живуть під
окупацією яка триває вже понад
років
усі ці ідеї приведуть у нікуди тому лише
тоді коли Україна повністю поверне собі
усі окуповані території і поверне додому
мільйони українців які там живуть і
потерпають можна буде говорити про
подальші кроки на нашу думку потім варто
буде зайнятися питанням правосуддя і
справедливості я про це говорю вдруге
але це дуже важливо тому що якщо питання
справедливості залишиться поза межами
майбутньої мирної угоди Якби вона не
виглядала тоді це означатиме що винні у
тисячах десятках тисяч воєнних злочинів
не будуть притягнуті до відповідальності
це не віуватиме нічого хорошого для
світового порядку також питання
репарацій відновлення країни має бути
розглянуто як частина цієї майбутньої
сподіваємося універсальної глобальної
угоди тому що було б недостатньо якби
Україна і Росія підписали мирну угоду
без участі інших великих країн окрема На
мою думку і Бразилії у питанні репарації
реконструкції відбудови України йдеться
про сотні мільярдів євро чи доларів США
Отже це питання яке також потребує
вирішення і є однією із запорук
тривалого миру і останнє але не менш
важливе питання Це звісно питання
майбутніх гарантій безпеки як запобігти
як дипломатичними засобами досягти того
щоб Росія в майбутньому не розпочала
нову подібну А може навіть більш
жорстоку війну це лабораторія для
дипломатів де вони можуть творчо мислити
шукати рішення Бразилія може відігравати
тут важливу роль як може виглядати ця
майбутня угода щоб жоден росіянин жоден
майбутній Російський уряд ніколи не
наважився почати подібну війну
продовжувати те чого вони не досягли Під
час цієї воєнної кампанії Під час цієї
війни яку переживає
Україна тож я сподіваюся що Т Мирне
рішення договір чи рішення будь-якого
іншого формату закріпить відновлення
Україною своєї Незалежності і
суверенітету а також зіграє важливу роль
для інших континентів для Латинської
Америки Африки Азії інших регіонів тому
що ніколи не знаєш напевне що може
статися це один з гірких на жаль дуже
гірких уроків які ми мали засвоїти щоб
мислити інакше в
майбутньому the
future